marina   mani al bagno
Sì barbara ci troviamo proprio qui nel bagno di marina qui alla mia destra potete vedere la sua doccia dove ha da poco girato
Il video sulle tipologie di ragazze in doccia qua invece troviamo una sua lacca e pensate un po
L'acqua micellare con la quale si strucca tutte le sere per adesso è tutto vada ti restituisco
La linea ci sentiamo dopo per gli ultimi aggiornamenti a te la linea ciao mariners come avrete intuito
Insomma la giornalista di poco fa vi Ha già anticipato che siamo proprio qui
Nel mio bagno a grande richiesta la mia prima make up collection
Queste sono tutti i miei prodotti, i miei trucchi, la mia vita, se vi state chiedendo perché non ci sono prodotti e di Salvo
E perchè è giusto così perché ci sono quattro scaffali ed è giusto che 4 scaffali siano solo per me, salvo ha un beauty-case grosso così e va più che bene diciamo.
partiamo subito dal primo scaffale innanzitutto una zona
Ombretti questi sono tutti ombretti le mie palette fantastiche di naked, questi di sephora queste di nabla
Delle ciglia finte che non uso. Da quando le ho comprate mi piacerebbe tanto provarle ma, non
ho ancora avuto voglia passiamo qua nella zona contouring, illuminanti, blush e
Ombretti questi sono gli ombretti e e fard cipria di tutto un po ecco è
Questa invece salerno che secondo scaffale la zona proprio propriamente più più foundation più tinte labbra più
Soldi che vanno come sempre senza nessun domani partendo proprio da re foundation questa mi chiedete spesso quale fondotinta uso
questo quadro baldi che I
Bianchissimo perché ovviamente misys carità. La pelle quindi sono più bianca. Del solito e
Anche per quanto riguarda. I correttori mischio mixò questi due sempre di urban decay che sono, I più chiari
sono casper il mio cugino
Gay e queste sono le labbra che avete già visto in qualche video se non erro in vita sulle tinte labbra chiaramente
è però nel video dell'intera però non avete visto tutti rossetti dovrei fare un video dove trovo tutti e rossetti questi sono tutti l'imac
poi
Ci sono certe questo partito che è buonissima e questi qua di cell phone poi c'è questo olio di chi sa che metto
prima insomma del fondotinta
Dei prodotti ni per. I pori per fare. La pelle un po più levigata un po più photoshoppata che dicono che la photoshop in realtà
Non, lo fanno per
e
Poi passiamo altri rossetti così non sono di marca sono di bobby brown che un altro
Brand che mi piace molto per quanto riguarda
Il make up questi qui sono dei ceroni che avevo comprato quando mi coprivo il tatuaggio e adesso lo sto togliendo come sapete quindi
non
L'uso più
Di tanto ma sono perfetti per coprire quei brufoli che proprio non riesce a coprire quel coretto al 12 di harley sopra il corre il
questo
gli toglie sempre
Passiamo a questo mi chiedete dove compro questi contenitori
Da cinesi ma è difficile trovarli cesi ci sono ovunque grazie
Per salvarci sempre la vita io mi rivolgo sempre a loro e questi fantastici nei contenitori
Portatrucchi mi trovo sempre lì e ogni volta che insomma mi arrivano dei prodotti nuovi completi con
frank e di nuovi contenitori perché sono dove li metto cioè quanto scaffali sono pieni
inizialmente rientra doccia risalgono proprio non può neanche entrare in bagno perché ci sono
questi cassettini dove o degli uni degli altri ombretti
toldi quali sono le palette qua ci sono gli ombretti diciamo singoli e ci sono anche quei fantastici ombretti tipo rosini e
Azzurrini chiosato nel video delle medie. Del riciclo ricordato tutti ecco qui tengo per vecchi dove tramite
Poi qua ci sono I mascara da ghiaccio
Poi ci sono I mascara da ghiaccio o parti al tender questo di clinique black ops
Mio tanti ma scarpa ghiaccio ovviamente un viaggio per niente quindi stanno di questo prende la zona a zona che non si apre mai
Qui ci sono dei correttori di quando ero una persona con un colorito un po più decente quindi può più scuri adesso non
Li posso usare ma. Se posso usare per fare. Il contouring perché sono troppo scuri e qui
Oa le matite per le sopracciglia in versione fa sempre da viaggio che sono ancora da aprire
Perché come ho detto non ne ho ancora avuto bisogno
Qui ci sono I beauty blender c'è questo che quello che uso più spesso però questi che sono praticamente
risalenti a decenni fa e quindi ritengo lì per bellezza e
Questi qui che mi sono arrivati da poco sono xtra carini si infilano dentro le dita però ti vuoi se non
Li ho ancora aperti il capire anche voi
Prendere prodotti nuovi avere prodotti nuovi ma non aprirli perché è bello comunque
così lasciarli lì e
ammirarli e sapere che ci sono
Potrebbero servire però per adesso stanno
Qui c'è una sezione mascara a grande richiesta farò anche un video sui miei mascara per adesso ve li faccia solo vedere qua ci sono
Due prodotti che mi sono arrivati da make up for ever un illuminante sposando molto e questo è un fondotinta che mi chiedo, non
Avere un presente chi fossi perché non mi puoi dare questo come fondotinta c'è un po ring people panor
Però grazie make up for ever e niente qua abbiamo finito questi sì
L'ho già tornato 26 ago, anche amianti ai piani alti c'è in più ti non. C'è più. Il make up
Ma non aspetta dimenticato questo la sezione più importante. I pennelli che è
la o
spessissimo
Con questo prodotto mi sono anche limitatevi farvi vedere cioè stiamo tornando ai piani bassi
Questo prodotto che vuol dire che ha dimenticato di far vedere è appunto un lava pennelli voi vi chiederete
Marina ma che cosa è questo oggetto strano è un lama pennelli ragazze lo so come se volete vedere funziona
E niente mette questo prodottino che vendono insomma apposta per questo aggeggio
Si prende e questo e si sceglie 2a. Del somma pennello che dobbiamo
Che dobbiamo lavare la dimensione di questo
chiamiamolo cappuccio in silicone che va a infilarsi qua poi a
Far salire e poi cosa succede questo adesso vi spruzzo tutto vale
Vedete è una figata perché il pennello gira, si lava. Dopo di ciò se lo alzate
Si asciuga quindi in questo momento il pennello si sta asciugando
e quindi quando
Spegnete il tutto non ci crederete mai mai pennello è pulito e asciutto
cioè questa è l'intenzione, del secolo un applauso chi ha alimentato style crew
E questi sono, I pennelli ci sono quelli penali in cui vado molto fiera tipo questo per il fondotinta
questo per
Fissante questo per il placet tutti. I pennelli di qualità
per quanto riguarda, I pennelli degli occhi farci
abbastanza pietà perché sono tremendi tipo questo mi è tornato
Questo che tutto duro perché non. Ho trovato
Non ho ben
Nove questo tipo nero perché era il contrario mini non, si vedeva che era sporco
E insomma, I pennelli per gli occhi diciamo che
dovrei darmi una sveglia e comprarli nuovi saliamo definitivamente in alto qua c'è una zona beauty e
Qua c'è tutta la sezione deodorante in cinque o sei perché a seconda
Di come mi sveglio metodi odoranti diverso questo è quello per pelli delicate
e
Qua c'è la crema di clinique che uso spesso come base
Qua c'è un'altra prima cosa come base e
Questa è la zona kills con questi prodotti molto idratanti e per pelli sensibili questa la maschera, non
Ho mai aperto forse perché è al pomodoro e diciamo che è un po ovunque tanto
Che altro non, so se profumerà
Questa è la mia crema corpo insieme a questa sempre per pelli delicate perché, ho la pelle più delicata di un bambino appena nato
borotalco
shampoo a secco sì ero da mettere a punto prima del trucco e
Questa maschera di kills la black mask che ho usato una volta, su salvo perché
dovevo
Testarlo su qualche cavia e infatti lo testate, su di lui poi, non
Ho mai più usata è questa invece tutta la linea benefit e appunto del per il viso con crema occhi contorno occhi
allora
Torniamo ai piani alti questi sono I piani alti per quanto riguarda
La cura dei capelli e o prodotti soprattutto
Di raskin di sue mura e di kérastase questa. La zona styling quindi voglio un cliente
crema insomma
Termica per da mettere prima di casa la piastra qui anche un prodotto termico qui è la mia, ricci quella linea
Volume sempre ricci e qui è la linea nutriente e diciamo che vi
Ho fatto vedere praticamente tutti I miei trucchi e tutti I miei prodotti qualcosa magari mancherà tipo le maschere che ho in quell altra sezione
però ragazzi
Come tutte le donne sono piena quindi potrei tirarne fuori anche dal soffitto
Ma quanto sono glamour I miei cotton fioc piano lo specchietto sono reclinabili
e hanno la punta per andare al punto a
Levare le
bella quello grazie all'aiuto da casa e
abbiamo subito la linea nostra vita giornalista si barbara e marina appena finito di girare un suo nuovo video
Ci teniamo tantissimo a far sapere agli spettatori di pomeriggio cinque che possono
Gentilmente iscriversi al suo canale se non. Hanno ancora fatto e
Attivare le notifiche cliccando sulla campanella accanto al tasso d'iscrizione e soprattutto a di seguirla
Su tutti gli altri social infatti marina non. Ha solo youtube anche facebook anche instagram era anche music
Ha ri. Correte a seguirla e top adoro atti la linea barbara